bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge avec le
ballet l'issue habdomadaire à partir
d'aujourd'hui et durant les prochaines
semaines on vous invite à nous suivre
sur les routes de la réunion à la
rencontre d'hommes et de femmes
passionnés d'agriculture etc ont
également à coeur de partager de faire
découvrir leurs pratiques et leur
quotidien à travers des visites guidées
ou simplement autour d'une table pour
cette première émission on se trouve
dans la région du maïdo on a fait une
petite halte ce matin histoire de
profiter du lever de soleil est là on à
bois-de-nèfles saint-paul quelques
kilomètres en dessous une pierre et
marie andrée où on verrait si la
ferme-auberge de bel air spécialisée
dans la production de canards et de foie
gras
je sais pas pour vous mais moi je suis
impatient de commencer cette nouvelle
saison en votre compagnie alors c'est
parti
ahmed foulant où ça l'a passée votre
matin avec café qui m'attend avec vous
la salle a passé 26 matin avec tapis
piloter elle y côtoie quittera somen ya
dix ans chacun il obtient d orange fait
d'immenses lacs hasnaoua bonjour pierre
joly sommes pas en forme
ouais alors voilà la ferme auberge bel
air et oui tu y es tu fais qu ici mais
nous on fait du canal du gavage de
canards ont fait table d'hôte sur moder
turf et des chambres a souhaité changer
s'emballe c'est la crise d'avoir purgé
passé d'avoir eu ici c'est quoi la table
ça c'est la table qui les gênait le
matin mais j'ai une maison d'avoir un
certain dit aussi d'accord et si la
table pour le petit déjeuner le matin
pour les repas des gens qui dorment dans
les chambres d'hôtes et était en train
de faire quoi elle a du coup mais
aujourd'hui rabattues et cana et dis moi
tu as commencé ta journal qu'est l'or ce
matin à 4 heures du matin quatre
indicateurs commencent ils à ramasser
les canada salle de gavage
ouais vous amener à l'abattoir on peut
battre à l'abattoir c'est une cure et tu
as fini la phase d'abattage là la phrase
au matin du filet d'accord donc il nous
a de quoi faire là on est en train de
les brûler ouais avant pour une fois est
bien comme il faut et puis après on va
sortir le faut ok bah écoutes je me
portais des lillois j'ai reçu c'est bon
alors voici la fameuse salle d'abattage
c'est ici que le car arrive c'est ici
qu'on les tue quand les plumes et après
ils passent dans la salle propre et on a
battu combien ce matin semader labatut
24 24 dans ce cas là il a fallu combien
de temps forts mais on a commencé à 4
heures du matin je vais à 8 heures
jamais cette recette ira bien
et donc du coup là maintenant on arrive
à quelle étape alors maintenant on vient
de fumer en lisant le nettoyer brûlé
nettoyer et on va passer à l'instruction
du foie d'accord et ensuite une fois
qu'une femme est enlevée ont causé le
tout les couples ou d'accord le point
coup ça peut faire des coups faciles et
magrets magrets séchés ou fumés ou
magret frais les cuisses et les mentions
s'ils pouvaient confie tout esprit tout
espoir d'extraire et tout ce qui va
rester comme carcasse on va fédérer y
est tu vois des particuliers sont placés
sinon pour tata sur place ça sert la
table on va au marché ont fait deux
marchés la possession au plumage
producteurs et on fait les ruches louis
russe qui lewis et sache que tu sais
s'il ya beaucoup de personnel de la
réunion du 8 août à l'île de la réunion
qui greffe du foie gras on doit être au
moins une dizaine ils nous aident à
ouais donc du coup la technique pour
extraire le foie gras
alors c'est qu'une fois sereine foie
gras c'est pour moi l'espoir à temps
pourquoi est un trop gros doigts où je
vais pas le voir on va s'habiller
d'abord la cabeza
je ne crois pas que tu vas y échapper on
est coupé retrouvez marie-andrée là bas
qui est en train d'extraire le foie gras
déjà bonjour mesdames c'est guillaume
qui ont fait qu'il va être l île foie
gras lui aussi je vous promets rien
ouais ah bah oui on enlève les pattes
après on commence à remarquer la voilà
un endroit où on va couper sentir le
foie la cei sur rien de vraiment très
grave il faut car n'est ce pas oublier
quand même que le grac le canada va
donner c'est ce qui va nous servir pour
nous confie une oreillette et tout ça
d'accord j'ai l'impression d'être dans
mes cours de bio lycée et à plat pour
trouver le l'endroit où on va passer au
couteau deux jeux peut être sentir oui
avant d'avoir mon propre canard oui
six emplacements ouais mais d'accord ok
là je vois là tu vas juste passé entre
les deux découper la petite membrane que
c'est ce qui va faire qu'on va préserver
aussi des malgré en général on comme on
fait ça à deux mois je fais toute cette
première partie ces mafias qu'un bluff
ou pas ses mains dessous et on va
chercher dessous s'est bien accroché par
guillaume respire alors tout va bien se
passer respire et là on tient bien le
coup sec et coup sec
d'accord on a fait un manteau une étude
de vous dire que c'est une première pour
moi je vais tenter d'extraire ce foie
gras
bah oui surtout rester dans le coin
parce que j'ai pas envie de quand même
eu deux semaines de gavage j'ai pas
envie de gâcher votre travail
elle a d'ailleurs en parlant du garage
on était venu ici à deux semaines pour
participer justement un gavage des
canards et et le temps que je finisse
d'extraire ce choix je vous propose de
revenir sur sur cette étape de la
production l'a à peine 7 heures du matin
et on va passer on va s'occuper des
canards et ça consiste en quoi
on va faire le gavage va pas parler
d'abord tout le match tout ce qu'il faut
pour gaver correctement chez canard
deuxième mariage mais dieu de l'huile
gaver le maïs pour gaver des canards tu
mets du maïs que tu que ton rock d'huile
pour que ce soit encore mais on a fait
on a fait tremper le match avec michel
d'abord et maintenant le lait de l'eau
et on met de l'huile pour permettre
meilleure des chances lui en dix ans
avant que ça marche encore vu à lui à
michel
la petite fille qui va bien l'énergie
alors on va commencer par ses parts des
modèles de canard ccd me lartigue millar
mal parce qu'on ne garde que les mâles
céder qu'une ad miller mal mais pourquoi
tu guettes que dès maintenant parce que
le foie le fond on l'avait mais n'est
pas bon
quatre vénules donc on grave que les
mâles et du gave tous les jours tous les
jours des fois par jour et à chaque fois
avec le même village ou augmentent tout
le monde tout le monde
là on a commencé à 200 grammes siècle 1
et ont terminé c'est 100 g siècle ah oui
alors le but c'est de presse et le
canard de l'ouvert son bec et d'enfler
youtube cameron tout sa mission on
appuie quand les deux sens sont nés g
sont rentrés latanya richardson ont fait
descendre un peu le maïs pour que soit
donc il arrive bien à l'estomac pas pour
lui et puis s'en va
ils mangent que du maïs rien d'autre à
ma place rapide et saint des saints la
dette atteint kitano la peau à pied
j'appuie pas traduits
pas cool et j'en fais quoi maintenant
ben maintenant tu le dépose dans le plat
dans l'eau froide et après au bout de
deux heures on les reprend et là on va
aller travailler
donc du coup on va avoir deux heures de
séchage d'égouttage le tout au frais
après on pourra le travail et c'est une
fête à l'abattage mais oui bah oui
j'imagine mais enfin c'est une fête pour
moi c'est une fête comment dirais je
oui c'est spécial mais pour nous c'était
un grand plaisir parce que on se
retrouve ensemble à faire ça et puis
après on mange un beau un bon repas et
ce midi on a quoi manger ce midi et vous
aurez du canal un froid serbe qui alors
fascinant
bon après un bond canard forestier deux
bonnes heures passées à table le temps
parfait pour laisser le foie gras
s'égoutter se raffermir un petit peu on
va pouvoir passer à la préparation en
elle-même
alors pierre ils ont le temps de bien
dégoûté oui j'aime bien écouter on va
passer du temps à tenir
on va commencer à enlever la déveine
parce que ça tu arrive parfois d'avoir
des petits poissons vraiment qu'ils
sachent pourquoi pas en gav
on ne sait on ne connaît jamais avoir
sorti les trois la grosseur du foie oh
mais c'est rare que ça arrive qu'on est
les vilains foie gras mais c'est par
exemple ce foie gras était mou quand tu
ne prends pas pu la voir passer au frigo
s'il est mou signé pas grave si il pèse
moins de 300 grammes
j'ai pas du foie gras pour rentrer dans
l'appellation foie gras il faut
absolument que le x passe la barre des
300 vincke
12 grammes de sel au kilo du poivre
blanc t il
nous voilà maintenant dans l'anneau fois
qu'ils sont là on va mettre cette
mixture qu'on a préparé
ah oui c'est juste saupoudrer ou alors
il faut quand même le faire bien
pénétrer
on va mettre 180 g
ah oui c'est vraiment du froid voire de
montrer
home est un peu d'alcool dedans en
l'occurrence du rhône ancien rhum
arrangé quête hacher d'où il ya du
femmes deux dans des ananas et un peu
tout et on verse une ampoule on ferme on
remplit autoclave avec les peaux de
l'epo de foie gras
l'autocar des plaies on le ferme voilà
au plat sans milieu des bombes et
l'appellation cuisson mais une demi
heure et les meilleurs on a eu des
mineurs çà me suis tout le temps d'aller
voir le gîte
ok la gamberge guette c'est pas bon même
un des matières on est où là on se
trouve là on est dans le cours de
peinture comme une personne dont on peut
y en a
six chambres occupées accueil à 10
personnes
et puis c'est pas méchant il faut le
dire de très bonne qualité quoi s'est
même fait des chambres il ya quand même
un espace appartement sa propre cuisine
en profite d'une vue qui est quand même
c'est époustouflante sa première chose
qu'on voit ici c'est bah oui enfin focus
son jacuzzi
c'est la deuxième touche trop vois je te
remercie pour tout ce fut un plaisir
pour moi de te montrer ce qu'on faisait
ce fut un solide pour moi de voir tout
ça je te remercie pour tout je te dis à
très bientôt à très bientôt et bonne
chose pourquoi je pour la suite merci
bronze on va voir et bien voilà une demi
heure de cuisson et je repars avec mon
foie gras mi cuit alors vous l'aurez
compris si vous voulez goûter à mais
emblématique de la gastronomie française
et cuisinés à la mode locale profiter
d'un cadre champêtre ou simplement d'un
jacuzzi
je vous donne l'adresse c'est la ferme
de bel air et ça se passe chez pierre
ici abonnés simple aller en ce qui nous
concerne on se retrouve très vite sur
les routes de la réunion